going to turn now to former President
Jimmy Carter who is resting at home and
receiving end of Life Care at the same
time messages of peace and comfort have
rolled in from thousands including
former presidents Bill Clinton and
George W bush yesterday friends and
family say that as always Carter is
comforted by a deep faith and on that
point our Robert Costa spoke with
Carter's close friend and former pastor
at the Maranatha Baptist Church right
there in Plains Georgia where Carter
taught Sunday school for decades
I've never met anyone like Jimmy Carter
not even close
when Jimmy Carter recruited Tony Loudon
to come to his hometown Church Louden
answered the call and the two formed a
special bond how tough is this time
for you
not only
have I
been able to be his pastor but it's
tough for me
because he's also my friend
Louden recalled being especially moved
by a trip they made together to a
historically black cemetery near Plains
the A's are pushing his wheelchair and
he's in his son the hot sun
pointing out that headstone right there
is Bishop William Decker Johnson
African-American
Amy Bishop who introduced me to Christ
now here's a father and son who the
father served in World War one and his
son served in World War II this Cemetery
where African-Americans have spilled
blood and built
Georgia
and fought for this nation
you know some in today's politics Will
Call that being woke
but he was aware and in recent weeks
Louden told us he's been visiting with
the former president who shared this
advice for him and all of us don't get
weary
be afraid
don't give up
because this is a great nation
Loudon told us he sees Carter as a
servant's leader with a servant's heart
and he said in recent days when they
have been praying together the former
president has been praying for others
jarika
so much history there Bob what a great
interview when you look at the life of a
man almost 100 years old and what impact
he's on had on his now Pastor a black
man at this time what a great story uh
thank you Bob